tesla's futuristic cyber truck straight
out of cyberpunk is your best option if
you're looking to get a truck apart from
being insanely cool and guaranteed to be
a showstopper it also comes with the
latest and greatest tech the electric
truck industry has to offer this tech
gives the tesla cyber truck several
significant advantages over its
competitors and in some categories even
blows the competition straight out of
the water what are these advantages and
just why should you get the tesla cyber
truck when other cheaper options are
available curious well you're in luck
because today we're going to take a look
at the top 10 reasons why you need to
buy a cyber truck now one the cyber
truck is bulletproof yes you heard that
right the cyber truck is bulletproof
tesla's cyber truck has been assembled
with a body made of 30 times cold rolled
stainless steel this steel is capable of
deflecting nine millimeter bullets
providing protection like no other truck
in the market the steel is also rust
proof and dent proof so unlike other
trucks that have to deal with corrosion
issues as they get older the tesla cyber
truck has absolutely nothing to worry
about the dent proof claim does seem a
bit far-fetched until you look at the
cyber truck launch events video of the
truck getting hit by a sledgehammer and
surviving without a scratch if this
truck is ever in a collision with
another car nothing is going to happen
to it as for the guy in the car well we
can only pray elon musk was asked in an
interview why he chose to make the cyber
truck bulletproof his reply you don't
want your truck to be bulletproof i
think we can all agree just how cool
owning a bulletproof truck would be two
the windows are shatterproof ever had
your car window break well with a
cybertruck you will never have to worry
about that again why well tesla borrowed
space grade shatterproof glass from
spacex for the cyber truck the same
glass that's going to mars is going in
the cyber truck and let's just say it
can handle pressure during the cyber
trucks launch event steel balls were
dropped on the glass with absolutely no
effect independent testers have also
tried breaking the glass with sledge
hammers but haven't been able to land so
much as a crack the reason for this is
the glass isn't made out of sand like
normal glass but instead it's a material
called aluminum oxy nitride or
transparent aluminum this material is
much more durable and shatter resistant
than normal glass offering a level of
protection no other manufacturer can
compete with with this glass and a
bulletproof steel body there's no way
anyone's ever breaking into your car
elon even called the cyber truck a road
legal truck because of the security it
provides to its users three one hundred
percent electric the tesla cyber truck
is one hundred percent electric it's not
hybrid unlike most other trucks and as a
result it is much easier to operate and
maintain you don't need to replace any
of the hundred other parts that a gas
operated or hybrid truck comes with
worst case scenario you'll need to
replace a chip or some wiring when it
comes to long-term ownership fully
electric trucks are the way to go 4.
fastest truck out there with a top speed
of 130 miles per hour and an
acceleration of zero to 60 in 2.9
seconds on the tri-motor version the
tesla cyber truck is the fastest truck
in the world the previous world record
was of 118 miles per hour which has now
been absolutely obliterated there are
people that say that you don't need an
acceleration as high as 0 to 60 in 2.9
seconds in a truck but we disagree there
are tons of places where you need
acceleration and honestly who doesn't
want a fast vehicle if your truck can do
130 miles per hour that's a huge plus in
our book what are your thoughts
regarding this is 0 to 60 and 2.9
seconds a gimmick or actually a useful
feature let us know your thoughts in the
comments 5. utility at the end of the
day utility is all it's about when it
comes to trucks and this is another spot
where the tesla cyber truck takes the
lead the tesla cyber truck comes with
100 cubic feet of space in its truck bed
now if you're wondering about getting a
ramp to get stuff into the truck bed
don't worry because tesla has you
covered the cyber truck comes with a
pre-installed ramp built into the truck
no more third-party ramps that break
midway if however you're thinking of
towing something and worried if an
electric truck has the power for that
you're in for a surprise the tesla cyber
truck has a towing capacity of 7 500 to
14 000 plus pounds it can even tow away
a ford f-150 as shown in a tug-of-war
video posted by none other than elon
musk himself to top it all off tesla
also has 120 and 240 volt outlets
installed so you can use it as a mobile
job site with this truck you won't have
to worry about getting a generator tesla
has got all your small time appliances
covered 6. best range electric trucks
have historically had a reputation of
some of the worst range when it comes to
vehicles this all stops with the tesla
cyber truck featuring a range of 500
miles the tesla cyber truck has by far
the best range of any electric truck in
the market this range is due to the
superior battery management software
installed on board working with
especially made batteries for tesla
tesla has been known to construct some
of the best batteries in the world and
while the batteries are the same
lithium-ion ones that everybody else in
the industry uses tesla just does it
better the argument that tesla doesn't
have a technological advantage when it
comes to electric vehicles as the entire
industry is using the same tech is
proved false here because if other
companies really have batteries as good
as tesla where's the range to prove it
7. the deposit is refundable you need to
deposit one hundred dollars to get into
the cyber truck wait list and secure
your position if you want a cyber truck
just pay the deposit anytime you feel
like this is not the greatest truck to
ever grace the earth just get a refund
if not you've got a first row seat to
the greatest development in vehicles in
modern times if you decide to get a
refund you might want to put that
forward for a less expensive tesla
cyberquad atv 8. self-driving option one
of the biggest reasons you should
consider getting a cyber truck is
because it comes with tesla's
self-driving software no other electric
truck in the market offers this feature
and it's only because of tesla's
previous work on its electric cars that
they have been able to come so far in
this field self-driving software is a
huge plus since you don't have to
constantly stare at the road just set
the truck to autopilot and check emails
take calls heck you can even have dinner
let the computer take the wheel and save
your time other companies are trying to
develop their own autopilot software too
but currently no company can even come
close to where tesla is the second most
advanced company waymo plans to release
self-driving taxis one day but
self-driving commercially available cars
not happening anytime soon if you're new
to self-driving software you might be
wondering about how the updates are sent
to the vehicle ford uses its service
centers and so does pretty much every
other electric car manufacturer you go
to the service station and pay to get
the latest software installed tesla
outdoes itself in this department too
tesla is currently the only electric
truck manufacturer in the world that
offers free over-the-air or ota updates
you don't even have to leave your house
just sit back relax and let the cyber
truck do its thing 9. loaded with
exclusive features tesla's product
satisfaction levels are off the charts
there are many things you can be in a
tesla but board is not one of them this
is because tesla does infotainment
better than anyone else their screen is
basically a built-in tablet and with
autopilot enabled you can binge watch
entire shows as you commute throughout
the day if you're getting an electric
truck tesla's cyber truck is the way to
go since all these features are tesla
exclusives only secondly there's also a
built-in metal tonneau cover unlike
other trucks where you have to spend
extra money getting a tonneau cover the
cyber truck is pre-installed with one
this cover is also better than any that
you might get through third-party
suppliers because one it is super
durable and made of metal and secondly
because it's motorized one press of the
button is all it needs 10. it's a
showstopper the tesla cyber truck has a
revolutionary design some people love it
and others well not so much despite all
this one thing is certain and that's the
fact that you're going to stand out when
you arrive with this bad boy next to you
if you're looking to make a statement
grab attention and turn heads the cyber
truck is the truck for you it's designed
in a way that's not too flashy yet
unique enough to make people stop and
look these were all the reasons why you
should get a tesla cyber truck hit the
like button if you enjoyed the video
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see more